what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
what's going on guys this is Robin every
once in a while we do an episode of the
rundown which is just like hey so here's
like this really really cool moment from
this story and I really liked it so I
want you guys to like YouTube and in
this one we're talking about the story
where the Joker decided to copy ride
fish oh there's like this like dude is
this is an amazing story there was an
episode of batman the animated series
called The Laughing fish which was
basically the same thing so history time
so like in the early 1970s this guy
Steve Englehart took over writing for
Batman and people talk about the Steve
Englehart Batman run like it's one of
the greatest sand longest-standing runs
of all time it lasted eight issues like
basically all of Batman the Animated
Series is based off like this a tissue
run but the whole idea like like this
picks up with a chick named silver st.
cloud okay so the whole idea behind this
is that Auguste switching back to the
modern-day like like undoing history
time so the whole the whole thing behind
this is that like silver st. cloud was
this chick who was created by by Steve
Englehart who's gonna be like this new
love interest for Batman right like like
this one chick who figured out his
identity Batman is the worst detective
ever and here's the reason why so silver
st. cloud throws on like this great big
huge like event right this huge gala cuz
she's like this super-rich chick with
blond hair it was like DC's attempt to
create silver sable but like no one
cared and so so this whole thing happens
criminals bust in I came over who it is
like so many busts in penguin to your
face whatever Cleo and like like she's
the only one who noticed I mean like
everybody notices because they all go
running and screaming all that kind of
stuff but she's the only one who notices
that Bruce Wayne leaves so she's kind of
looking around and she's like does
anybody ever notice that like when Bruce
Wayne leaves Batman shows up like a
wonder if Bruce Wayne is Batman so it
sounds like she shouts out his name
right she's like Bruce Wayne and in his
infinite wisdom the world's greatest
detective Batman turns around and looks
at this girl
good job Captain Obvious
so like so she's like I knew it I knew
it but like doesn't actually say
anything right cuz she's kind of like
okay well you know I'll just keep this
secret to myself so like that man's like
oh man like like my detective skills
have deduced that I think she knows my
identity because I'm an idiot so he goes
over to this girl's house in the middle
of the night right like that's not
creepy at all like a guy dressed as a
bat shows up at a chick's house in the
middle of the night so he's like hey
what's going on girl she's like he's
like like not really that he's just like
may I come
like does this as he helps himself like
like just walks in he was no she's like
she's like wearing a towel she's like oh
hey Batman what's going on
Batman see anything you like he's like I
see everything I like so so like so he
starts talking to this girl he was like
he's like what do you know about Bruce
Wayne and like like she's she's for clay
she's standing like she doesn't know
right the whole time like Bruce Wayne is
putting on this whole facade about
Batman now here's a funny thing the
silver st. cloud
this guy looks like an idiot right like
he's he looks like that one high school
kid and you know I'm you know I'm
talking about like that without man
y'all know what I'm talking about that
one high school kid who would like wear
an eyepatch to look tough maybe in your
school it wasn't it wasn't a kid with an
eyepatch I'm not talking about nerds
being a Nerdist badass I'm talking about
like that one kid who was trying to look
cool and so it's just like okay like
come on man
no one thinks you're cool no one
believes you lost your eye in a bar
fight because you're 15 years old like
like come on man like just just be
yourself all right just like be the nerd
you know and just be awesome you know
but anyway so so so Batman looks like a
total goof right looks like a total goof
in front of this girl and so she's like
well maybe I should like like tell him
you know that I know his name is Bruce
Wayne but did again this is a guy who is
completely and totally mentally unstable
climbs into people's windows in the
middle of the night dressed as a bat
while at the same time beating people up
all over the place so so she's like okay
I'm gonna keep mine I'm gonna keep this
to myself and so Batman's late so so bad
news okay I guess she doesn't know
because my detective skills have led me
to believe there's no conceivable way
that her body language is giving off the
idea that she's fighting anything and so
so he's like okay cool like you don't
know what he thinks so he leaves and
she's like all right whatever
all right so she's had enough right like
like in this story she basically ends up
taking off I should be sealians up
leaving because she's like dude this
guy's crazy as hell I'm tired of dealing
with this with this crazy man that's new
yeah I remember guys every woman has
three lists she's got the friendzone
list she's got the boyfriend list and
she's got the mistakes she made when she
was younger list and like that's that's
like Batman is on the mistakes I made
when I was younger less that's his whole
thing so anyway so Batman is like okay
well I guess I'll just go out and do my
own thing and beat up criminals Evan
there's like this this dude on a dock
right he's just like oh nice
so that means like I wonder what could
be going on so like the like Batman
shows that the dude shows him a basket
full of fish that look like the Joker
Batman is like oh my god like I've got
enough going on right now I've got some
crazy chick who I think figured out my
identity but she thinks I'm like a crazy
guy from high school who wore an eye
patch I've got so much going on right
now like I really don't have time for
Joker in his insane antics but people
are freaking out because you're like hey
man this is our source of income dude
this is how we make our money so like
you need to do something about this
Batman because you're a superhero and
we're too lazy to do anything for
ourselves
all right so pick up in like this
Copyright Office right with this dude
named Francis so Joker codes rolling in
right like Joker comes rolling he's like
hey what's going on everybody the office
like aha
because like the Joker's here it's like
madness this is not gonna go anywhere
but anywhere but bats like Francis so he
walks into Francis he's like hey man so
I don't know if you noticed Home Slice
but like all the fish in the eastern
seaboard looked like me and so so
Francis is like yeah man like they do
kind of look like you Joker so what's
your point he's like well I want to
copyright them and it's like it's like
you want copyright fish man you can't be
copyright in fish like you man you came
but you can't do that Joker you can't
copyright fish wrong wrong answer so so
so so Francis Francis it gives a bad
information Joker's like okay look man
like this is gonna go one of two ways
either you can like let me copyright
fish or you can die cuz I mean we kind
of have to make arrangements for this
kind of stuff you know and so he asked
him a question Francis goes to answer
and you hook her back back as the hell
out of him he's like you deserve this
for having the name Francis and he's
like I always answer questions myself I
always answer my own questions walk it
on the Joker and I'm crazy so so the
Joker's like look man this is happening
all right like like this is this is
gonna happen to imagine this imagine
like if I copyrighted fish man like all
my schemes would be done I would have to
rob anything anymore now to be honest if
I were Francis I would have pushed it
through I would sit there and weigh the
odds 1 I've got a crazy guy dressed as a
clown in my in my office who's probably
gonna kill me in two if it means that
the Joker is gonna stop being Joker then
I would be like yeah man you can
copyright fish whatever man I was like
here you go here's a copyright permit
for fish you know like like Long John
Silver's good luck I mean honestly I
think it'd be kind of cool like you got
a Long John Silver's you just get like a
joker like a joker looking fish you know
like let me get the number 5 hold the
Joker I'm just saying I think if you got
a fight so anyway phrases rejects the
whole thing right so the Joker's like
okay fine like you know you're gonna pay
for this you know so he is I'm just
leaving ends up walking off all right
now pick up with this guy named Rupert
thorne Rupert thorne was a creation as
far as I'm aware of by Steve Englehart
and he was basically designed to be like
this new villain in town and it's kind
of crappy because what you had
I believe from correctly you had this
huge auction and it was the auction for
the identity of Batman and Rupert thorne
was the one who won and so Joker shows
up and visited Rupert thorne right in
the most like in the most uncomfortable
way possible like Rupert Thorne's in
like the men's room he just finishes up
using the bathroom so Joker comes
rolling up on Rupert thorne he's like
hey man ah so I heard you got the
identity of Batman and and Rupert
Thorne's like yeah man
Joker please like don't kill me because
I know you're crazy as well the Joker is
like hey man alright here's here's the I
here's the idea I need the Batman
alright like I kind of had I got to have
Batman if I don't have Batman the things
just aren't aren't what they need to be
so like you gotta let me have Batman so
so he's like you can get out of town man
is what you could do you can basically
be out of town and in basically sounds
like Rupert thorne go crazy whatever
Rupert thorne loses mine who cares
anyway this is like a throwback to the
old school things right so like Joker
jumps on TV right it's a throwback to
the old like like Batman number one
whatever was Joker first showed up when
he killed mayor Haiti and he shows up he
says okay guys like hey everybody on
national television
at least local television you know local
channels probably interrupted by some
terrible commercials the heavy-hitter
you guys know I'm talking about that
lawyer guy uh-oh if you guys have that
in your town but like we have this guy
he's like the heavy hitter he's like
this lawyer
he looks so seedy like he looks like a
mob lawyer and it's just like like I'm
the heavy hitter you know and whatever
his guy got Superbowl Tom won so he's
got some money anyway so he jumps on TV
he was like hey so Karl gee Francis
wouldn't let me copyright fish so he's
gonna die so he's gonna die it like this
exact time so so good luck so what
doesn't happen he's like Batman goes
over to his house right he's like okay
look you know we got to keep an eye on
out here we got it we gotta figure out
what's going on you know we got to get
everything sorted now here's a funny
thing Batman and Joker fought before
right this whole situation has unfolded
before this is why Batman has the worst
detective ever so Batman like Batman's
like okay I want to put this you know
this this thing over his face
everything's gonna be okay and then like
like Francis is exposed to like this
chemical in the exact same way that like
mayor Haiti was and then Francis died
the same way mayor Haiti did Batman's
like all my goodness you know I didn't
think of the one thing that would have
been the most obvious for Joker exposed
him to a chemical in the Copyright
Office and this is the secondary
chemical and now he's dead golly gee I'm
the world's greatest detective
so phrases is dead right and they're
like okay so the Joker is like I'm gonna
keep killing people until like my my
request is approved by the city because
I'm the Joker and that's what I do
okay so the next person on the Joker's
list is this dude named Jackson right
he's like that he's like the next person
under France and so so so Batman is like
okay I have an idea guys
like in my infinite wisdom and my genius
detective skills which have proven to be
infallible
we're gonna do we're gonna dress up
Jackson as Batman the most sought after
person in the in the city of Gotham at
any point in time they could you know
like like you could just descend on the
house okay guys we gotta take out Batman
before we get to Jackson because
Batman's gonna get away a thing so let's
put him in harm's way all right so so
what happens like like the Joker sets a
cat loose right he's just like okay so
like the internet loves cats so like you
know everybody loves cats like they're
they're gonna be like oh man look at
that cat is so adorable
it's so cute you know like like hit like
captain whiskers you know so like they
they send captain whiskers into the
house right so captor whiskers ends up
taking a bite of one of the gel he walks
in with a joker fish and it's like oh my
god so bad there's oh my god do the
cat's affected with it with the Joker
with the Joker toxin so uh captain
whiskers becomes captain smiles
so captain smiles turns around and like
immediately jumps at Batman right
there's like oh dude man he's gonna turn
Batman in delight and he's gonna kill
him and that's exactly what happens so
like so we end up finding out the
diamonds dresses jax-ur than that was
there was it so Jackson's dead man let
me tell you some an it sucks being
friends with Batman when you're friends
with Batman you die and so I was like I
don't like it bad I don't have anything
doing anymore so Batman's like okay we
got it we got to sort this out we got to
figure this out so Batman takes the
fight to the Joker right and so doing
what he should have done in the first
place which was tracked the Joker down
before any of this could happen
the Batman finally locates him I so
Batman comes running up on Joker he's
like all right look man this this needs
to end right now like I've had enough of
this whole thing like this this needs to
come doing it what follows is one of the
craziest things ever Joker's like
shooting like like like the poison acid
stuff out of his little of Hell thing
out of his little flowers so you should
have things a Batman that nurse goes to
punch of Joker dodges and then like like
just takes off and it's just like this
cat-and-mouse game with her fleeing over
the rooftops it were say clouds long
since gone Hoover thorns like man I got
to get while the getting's good like you
so they're just kind of like chasing
over rooftops and all I kind of get
stuff in Batman's like oh gosh golly my
combat training it's all come to bear in
the fact that I'm being outran by a guy
in a purple suit with no real athletic
training whatsoever so Batman finally
catches up with him I finally catches up
with the Joker they end up like on this
little high-rise thing my Joker falls
off any lands in the water and Batman's
like okay well I guess everything's
alright and then leaves usually okay
he's like what the Joker fell in the
water
what's the worst that could happen I'm
sure he's gone now like that's the end
of that's the end of Joker and then he
just takes off like silver st. cloud
finally tracked him down right she's
like hey I know what your identity is
Batman like I know that you're Bruce
Wayne and and okay now let's now let's
be honest here folks if I were Batman
and somebody rolled up on me and was
like I know your identity as
Swayne that would be like I'd snap your
neck call me cold-blooded man I would
I'd be like what you know what's over
st. Cloud you're going to the water with
Joker and that'd be the end of it
because I'd be like look my idea needs
to be protected
all right and that's gonna be it so so
like I mean honestly I would have taken
care of her but that's it like Joker
falls into the water Batman's like the
day is saved cuz Joker fell in the water
he couldn't possibly survive that you
know because it's the Joker whatever
comic books and like that's it like he's
just like okay let's go swing from
buildings again and you know and and I
guess that's the end of the story it's
interesting but it's weird because like
this this is like this story shows that
man to be his most inept but he's like
the most inept detective ever like is
it's it's it's weird to me anyway if you
guys are new here to comics explain make
sure you guys have the sub button to
become part of the rock or if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]